fermée jusqu'à nouvel ordre voilà ce que
tu as quelques hommes armés et cagoulés
sur les locaux l'union européenne à gaza
l'autre menace directement les
ressortissants français danois et
norvégien frappé lits dont la presse a
publié des caricatures du prophète
mahomet d'où sont associés islam et
terrorisme
les menaces des groupes palestiniens
interviennent dans un contexte interne
troublé mais ici comme ailleurs la
poussée de fièvre est réel et de boycott
des produits danois prend de l'ampleur
la polémique est aussi hexagonal la
publication par françois dans son
édition d'hier des douze caricatures a
suscité de vives réactions chez une
partie des musulmans de france
dire que le prophète de l'islam est un
prophète terroriste d'avancé faux et
vous n'avez pas le droit on n'a pas le
droit de dire que c'est l'homme que nous
vénérons chacun de nos instincts de nos
jours est un prophète qui a fondé une
religion terrorisme dalil boubakeur a
reçu le soutien de responsables
chrétiens et juifs
dès lors que quelqu'un gros en relief de
chose casser cette croyance de façon
irrévérencieuse et provoquant
productrice ne paraît pas être
d'appartenir à la liberté de presse
france-soir persiste et signe son
propriétaire l'homme d'affaires
franco-égyptien raymond hakkar chrétien
convaincu a pourtant révoquer le
directeur de la publication daisy hier
mais aujourd'hui son rédacteur en chef
défend la position du quotidien notre
position ne change pas nous considérons
que ces caricatures ont le droit
d'exister
voilà c'est un principe intangible
la liberté d'expression c'est cela au
nom de ce principe la liberté
d'expression de plus en plus de journaux
européens publient les caricatures qui
font scandale alors que les politiques
et les diplomates tentent de calmer des
esprits chauffés à blanc
nous
sous l'oeil du religieux le crayon du
dessinateur utilise l'interdît pour
mieux afficher sa liberté
c'est la réponse de plantu à la une du
monde de ce soir réponse aux
protestations des musulmans après la
publication par plusieurs journaux
européens de ces caricature représentant
le prophète mahomet à charlie hebdo
la réaction est unanime menacé en 2002
après la publication de dessins de
mahomet l'équipe de l'hebdomadaire
rejette tout interdit dictée par les
régions le pacs est évident qu'il faut
être ferme pas être agressif il faut
joyeusement dire non chez nous c'est pas
comme ça les amis vous êtes libre de
preuve ce que vous voulez mais ça nous
on fait ce qu'on veut la liberté
d'expression c'est sacré choc et pour ça
on est au pays de zola et voltaire n'est
pas au pays de l'ayatollah khomeini tu
sais ce dessin qui a le plus choqué les
musulman mahomet cachant une bombe dans
ce à quoi pour le dessinateur algérien
dilemme
l'émotion est compréhensible même si la
liberté de la presse doit être préservé
c'est vrai qu'il ya matière à choquer a
choqué quand même quand même les
musulmans et les musulmans les musulmans
du monde du monde entier mais faut
surtout pas non plus livré maintenant
ces dessinateurs à la vindicte
populaires généraux c'est ce n'est que
des dessins même comme alité du côté du
dessinateur pétillon auteur de l'album
la sphère du voile consacré au voile
islamique
ces dessins je trouve qu'il manque
singulièrement de subtilité mais c'est
une question de principe
il s'agit la liberté d'expression et si
ces dessins peuvent être considérés
comme
faisons comme des appels à la violence
je ne sais quoi c'est aux tribunaux d'en
décider
en définitive c'est la représentation du
prophète mahomet qui est au coeur du
problème une représentation non prévue
par le coran mais exclu par la tradition
la tradition musulmane a beaucoup
insisté sur sur cette affaire avec
représenter dieu représenté pour fait
c'est le tabou j'aime dire le tabou des
tabous entre liberté de la presse et
souci de ne pas provoquer ce débat sur
les caricatures de mahomet pose une
nouvelle fois le problème de la
protection des libertés d'expression en
démocratie